welcome welcome to your mom's house
[Music]
above us skunk number two by Ross dude
English you're going to say lose tits
I'm there yes September 22nd and 23rd
and here iam comedy krub definitely not
LA but I've never been to st. lous tits
of you many times what should I eat
there you gotta have I always have pork
sliders what they're known for
October 3rd narshe ville tenant tenant
its yep 10th its
Zanies come club October 4th Charlotte
North Carolina the comedy zone and then
October 8th with my jeans live your
mom's house live in sperm vine
California and that's it until 2018 guys
mama likes to take the holidays at home
you know what I'm saying
holler at your boy September 27th two
shows in Albany at the funny bone first
one sold out second one only had like 30
tickets left so by the time you hear
this I don't know what's left the next
day writing Pennsylvania the Santander
Performing Arts Center the next day the
State Theater September 29th in Portland
Maine and the end the week at the big
ole Sony Center for the Performing Arts
in Toronto Ontario Canada part of jfl 42
in Theriot that's the province I'm fun
that is the province you're from and I
go from there I'm home for a little bit
and then I go to Ann Arbor Indianapolis
and the hard rock hard cock yeah it's
gonna say come see know and Northfield
just outside of Cleveland Ohio I go to
st. lous tits then later in October oh
you do yeah and then fart go north kept
North Dakota so I've not been there but
I like the TV show it's fantastic in the
movie so yeah that's that I'm very
excited go to Tom Segura DICOM slash
tour or go to christina PE
online.com that's its new identity with
my special dropping Christina P it's
Universal October turns uh-huh October
8th okay bye palm cast palm kiss all
right gene a lot to get into
let's get the show on the road here we
go well this is new tonight a family has
had enough they say a woman is
defecating on their sidewalk near briar
gate and Union in Colorado Springs the
family says they've caught her in the
act twice now they've begged her to stop
but now Springs Police are getting
involved don't bring anyone
[Music]
the mad pooper Colorado Springs that's
good I thought for a second when I heard
this story that it was you know cuz I
was in yeah I thought it was you anytime
now this is a very handsome news
reporter what what she's a very handsome
woman why do you say that it's kind of
like it looks like a dude with a bomb
ear cut right like legit is it a
transgender no that's not why are you
doing that
that's not nice what listen here's what
I'm being a jerk about this stuff
because if you work in television
you should be attractive babe god you're
vicious sometimes well it's the truth I
demand the same excellence from the
male's too just so you know what's your
pronoun well there you go
I'm harsh around the guys believe me
actually she really is I know especially
the old town basset hounds they have i
Morley Safer ESP yeah he's dead yeah
yeah I think he died the week after he
retired he retired and he died like a
week later maybe a month yeah got to
work right up until the end huh I know
it is funny cuz you were the first
person to point that out to me and I'd
never thought about it so one of those
things you don't think about where you
would walk by the TV and you'd be like
they allow this guy on TV and I'm like
what you're like he's so ugly they would
never let a woman like that on TV never
and then I was like I started to look
the more you think about it as you watch
TV if you if you've never thought about
it think about it now and you're like
that's definitely true now that dude
looks like a dog shit hot dog shit old
dog shit and if you look at especially
in the sports world like now they got
where it says that they got these cuties
down on the ground
yeah interviewing the coaches and
they're hot their hair is all curled and
tendrils and they've got the the other
thing I hurt yeah oh yeah the little
hotties on the sidelines that's it
that's been a phenomenon for the last 15
years or so but the and like yeah
sometimes you're like does she wait but
yeah is she really understand sports cuz
I sure some of them really really I'm
sure yeah but then he got the basset
hound game
that's the ESPN guys after I'm talking
about the game for five hours and you're
like these guys look like shit I'd look
like shit the other thing is uh their
dad jokes I would even get into the
point of unbearable just accepting their
humor like being like oh that's part of
it and now I judge it more harshly like
these fucking tools making their
terrible jokes and they're like right
like Scott what he's doing right now and
then they're like oh and they act like
it's really bad and especially because
they can hire comedy writers there's no
shortage of funny people in the world to
write for you suppose it locker room
banter like them just being guys but a
lot of it's super terrible yeah I can't
I I don't even watch it with you that's
your one that's I would say the one
thing you and I really don't share as a
hobby as is football but I'll walk no
I'll walk into the room and I'll hear
some stupid with that joke and finally
you can have separate interests yeah no
of course no I know I'm just like yeah I
feel like some people are like you know
the whole we do everything together we
do it all together
no we're were bonded pair that means we
do everything I feel like we should jump
into the fact that I mean obviously this
young lady is in Colorado and which we
were there I shot a special this weekend
that's right in Denver and mom for
Colorado and it was an awesome awesome
experience great night thank you to
everybody that came out I even added a
show the night before at Comedy Works
and that was really fun I was so scared
going into the week because I was sick
the sickness that you know here in
Christina's voice thank you and I was
anxious man cuz you know you're going
into a taping and you don't feel good
and your coffee when your throat doesn't
feel right and nasal drip I mean it was
it was terrifying I mean I really had
anxiety about it not about the show just
about being sick you know and thankfully
the the day of the the night before the
show if honestly I had considered
cancelling that comedy work show because
I was like what am i doing
you know I'm taping tomorrow I don't
feel good I'm doing another show I don't
need to do this show but
I was like I'll just do it and I did it
and then I was like I'm going to bed
and I I got some nyquil took my meds and
I got good sleep like I got solid you
know eight hours or something
all right well cup and I was like I
don't feel like absolutely dragging like
I'm exhausted right now and that put me
in a good mental place that like I got
good rest I was still sick but I was I
was coming out of it you know like a
something right now I just have like the
lingering last effects of it but I had
the I had the you know the thought like
okay I'm well enough to get through and
then you arrived and I got I got sick
before I came and then right and the
kids said but I'm saying when you got
there we were like we should do
something like no let's just get in beds
we got in bed this is why we're married
yeah and we get and we tried to I think
we slept for like another half hour or
something like yeah and then we got
lunch and then it was like okay like the
routine you know the day is getting
going and we just kind of we eased into
it just took it easy yeah and then that
night I mean that was nuts right like
those crazy you know and I didn't
realize cuz I haven't been going with
you on these shows like I've just been
only hearing about them we don't travel
together anymore because of the kid
really is how many fucking people were
there like you've told me the numbers
and then until you see like a theater of
people who are so geeked to be there and
these people were so pumped it was so
fun I was like oh my god like how are
you this normal like if that were me and
probably just be freaking out like I'm
gonna hate everything wait why do you
say that I just have a negative
self-talk but you I feel like how does
it not make you like an unbearable
egomaniac right I'd be like I don't know
how how you deal with it you think
that's normal I mean there's so many
people here I'm not an unbearable you go
maniac to begin with you're not it's not
your nature but you do you do dislike
people
I mean someone somewhat but I mean I
like you know it's funny I was like we
talked about things on this
like I always make jugs but like I don't
like crowds and I don't like I don't
want to fucking you know I have I've had
jokes in my act like I'm all friended up
and all this stuff yeah when you say
those things in your act and you talk
about it then people end up like people
I meet people after shows and they go I
know you don't want to meet me right now
and I'm like now cuz it's always super
nice people
yep worse oh my god no what I'm talking
about just the masses you know like wow
a lot of nondescript I think people
individually are great yeah it's the
crowds weird you know it'll make you
hate people going to an NFL game all but
went to the Broncos game and like you
just see I mean there's great people of
the game but there's just the loud
obnoxious drunk scumbags that Stadium
you're like oh my god can they just put
these people down there should just be a
scumbag area where like if you want to
be drunk and annoying go there you know
what I was I was amazed by that should
the restraint that I saw these like they
were throwing a guy out and he was
wearing a purposely gigantic oversized
cowboy hat and he was a Cowboys fan
because the Cowboys were playing the
Bronco and him and his friends were
getting tossed out and he was just like
today's guy he's like fuck you you
fucking pigs and I was like who in
society does that like who scumbags
right like put you dirtbags we were just
watching him like how out of your mind
are you there well you're like suck it
you fucking pigs
to the to like kick Hobbs and the
security cops no please yeah like he's
and he's like you fucking pigs and like
double did a double birds and like
pointing to his dick fuck you you piece
of shit and and then they're kind of
slowly walking towards like very calmly
and they're like yeah and then he kept
backing up and he had this giant
oversized hat on like not a regular
cowboy hat it's like purposely I know
yeah and then I look over at other cops
in the in the car and they're looking in
there
like smiling and I was like you sitting
there like can't we see him I see him I
think it's like your life sucks and then
you're gonna take it out on the police
at the game yeah you're a football game
well that's what that's why people act
fools in public right yeah they can't
control their lives and they get out in
public and they they're gonna control
this right I'm gonna I'm gonna show them
man
as much as I like Bravo as much I like
football every time I go to a game I
regret going to a game yeah well cause
it's the it's the uncontrolled masses
yeah yeah it's just as a collective we
suck as human I think I would like to go
to a game if I could get a field pass I
mean cool stand on the sidelines for the
simple fact that I would love to watch
football alive and not be near another
human being now can't you get like super
private boxes yeah I've done boxes I I'm
conflicted about boxes boxes are really
like it's I guess it's kind of the it's
a it does isolate you and it's kind of a
luggage it's a nice feeling right it's
nice it's nice but no it's good
perspective you know like you see the
game but I feel kind of removed from it
I mean you know like when you go to like
whatever a high school game you know you
can you can walk on the sideline or like
close to it you know I like I like being
like down on the field I do like it
and I know you can get that I've talked
to some people about getting a field
pass to a game before and they're like
yeah we can arrange that but I mean it's
you know it's not like you can you go on
StubHub feel pass it's like you have to
give to me it should be special get the
big calls yeah I like that I like that
you're out about hating people I like
that on you out at me on this show about
being an LA snob and how you hate
everywhere I hate everywhere that's not
home it's not la it's not la yep I don't
even give a shit my favorite part about
that for you though is because I kind of
feel this way a little bit too um
everybody feels free to shit on LA like
it's like a you know and so a lot of
times people are like when I meet them
like where do you live I live in LA
they're like I can't stand it and like
worth fuck do you live and then they you
know they list wherever Toledo or
something I'm like is that great and
they're like I like it I'm like yeah I
like where I live to fuck you
right that's kind of how I feel about it
it's it's not that I think la is better
than everywhere else it's familiar to me
no I don't like unfamiliar I would like
to correct you
you think la better it's better for me
because I'm it's familiar to me I'm like
I know there are better places to live
in the world what's great about being
home oh yeah it's home and like I like
my nice weather I don't care about the
traffic it doesn't bother me and I'm
fucking care about celebrities doesn't
bother me yeah I like it when people go
I can't do all that Hollywood stuff and
don't worry about it you won't have to
yeah I like avocados I like fresh
produce
yeah I like oranges and stuff that
aren't grey know what's you I mean grey
bananas that's what I see on the East
Coast when I go to these places like
Buffalo Siri quit ever it's it's all
grey bananas bananas from dude come to
California shit's all yellow here
fucking bro bro yeah I don't even know
what an avocado looks like I've been in
parts of this country where they've not
even seen an avocado your fruit ain't
the right color man shit from Mexico
dude wait can we talk about this pooper
yeah we can but I also wanted to one
last I mean I really wanted to say it
meaningfully thank you to everybody in
Denver because that was that was a
thrill for me to shoot a special in a
city that I've I know I've always told
you I love Denver I do and you guys came
out and that the shows were fucking know
they're so fun it's going to be such a
great special and I'm really excited for
people to be able to see it on Netflix
right yeah yeah we'd be on Netflix do we
have an ETA on when it may drop now
people keep asking me I mean I they
haven't told me they all park they'll
give me ballpark I know that typically
they do to three to four months turn
around yeah but sometimes they change it
up so we just don't know that's true cuz
I fill mine in June and then it's
dropping in our tours was like right on
that schedule yeah so there you go
so around there all right so there's a
lady pooping in college but the altitude
gets me every time in mom ver I'm very
sensitive to it yeah yeah it does if I
can't breathe and stuff
like the altitude Spencer this is so
what is so gross you ever hear somebody
say that according to the buddy family
about once a week they're getting all
too familiar with the paper towels she
wipes with surprise she nasty she's so
nice I didn't get to take off that
one-piece spandex unitard
I think she's wearing a one-piece unit
sorry that means she's got to strip
completely naked to take a shit yeah so
she's getting down to titties she crazy
as hell right that's crazy
Cathy buddy and her family have had
enough and it's not like it's private
people can see you I mean we're saying
her pants around ankles in broad
daylight
her kid saw it happen first I think
screaming you know you're not gonna
believe this they're like crying like
Wyatt and you're like there's a lady
taking a boat and so I came outside he's
like oh and I was like are you serious
are you really taking a poop right here
and burn my kids and she's like yeah
sorry just yeah sorry
she didn't have an excuse yeah okay
diarrhea can't find a bathroom or like
it's clearly a runner so I could get if
you're like oh this happened you know
like I panicked this urgency but doesn't
sound like that's what's happening cuz
running makes you have to poop yeah but
I mean so I'm saying like in the running
I've done I've still never had to be
like oh my god right now right here I
have to go like maybe this lady has a
bowel problem like an 80s thing but
listen to this though Kathy says if that
was it there wouldn't be a problem and
so I thought for sure she's mortified it
was an accident
so go get a dog bag come back clean it
up no no and never run here ever again
not the case Kathy says the runner knows
what she's doing and comes with napkins
in her pockets and here's the other
thing this is this is why I have a
theory on this there's a bathroom across
the street right here our Park has
porta-potties and there's a gas station
right here she's even working on an
embarrassing smear campaign posting this
sign to get her to cut the well you know
cut the
no local news humor
this lady is totally getting off on
shitting in public that's this is the
equivalent of a man who pulls his dick
out you know it is you mean it's a
sexual arousal or necessarily section
power playing there's a thrill there's
some type of thrill going on she likes
she likes taking a dump in public you're
wiping it there either people seeing her
and going like are you really doing this
and she's like yeah or discovering it
she gets a thrill out of doing it I can
see it actually now that I knew you
explained it that way I could see myself
doing that and getting that's not
supposed to don't you feel like it no
because it's sneaky and now that she
knows they're on her a game is
escalating and you have to now it's a
real challenge like she's she knows
she's doing a naughty bad yeah dirty
thing yeah she's breaking the law mm-hmm
and it's just a matter of time before
they catch her though it is I mean
there's gonna wait for her can they just
wait for her oh yeah they're definitely
any book people that watch this in that
community I'm sure they probably have
pegged here by now I'm sure what's the
penalty for shitting in front of well
they're gonna they're gonna trump up
some charges well what's the charge
public indecency probably yeah that's
disgusting bottom line is its disgust
really officers have asked Kathy to snap
some pictures of the runner and get the
word out hoping she does stop before
indecent exposure and with defecation
charge a natural thing we would do in
our society to sure it is
drop your trouser and relieve yourself
take shit when you know there's people
around especially I could be more
natural than taking a shit
Kathy let me know she's had other people
come forward and say that they have the
same thing happening to them they've
seen that woman relieve herself outside
of a Walgreens and in people's backyards
you know who she is
police would love to hear from you got
it back to you it's clearly a thing now
yeah she's she's done it in front of
Walgreens
man I mean that's her thing let her do
it I don't know what the big deal is
yeah no she's that's foul man and she's
shitting in front of people's kids like
you're fucking you're nasty
that's disgusting yeah so disgusting I
don't know there's worse crimes in
society I was definitely worse crimes
but like human shit is it's harsh
she's taking a runner shit it's that's
so funny you know how many of my friends
sent this to me by the way yeah all of
them yeah they know what this shows
about man bro I like when they use the
the technical word when they're like
this woman is defecating and I guarantee
you a lot of the people listening don't
know the word defecating yeah
defecating is Americans would they
guarantee it taking shit from your
fucking house bro have you heard that um
that I'm crazy
from Bill burr yeah yes I've heard the
rumor mill and not a rumor
what do you feel about it of course what
have I been making fun of you for for
forever that laughing woman I shouldn't
laugh right which means that you on some
level it resonates with you what do you
think of the wrong evil oh boy you're
really quiet sometimes when you stand
next to I just peer into his head
sometimes like what's going on in there
you're a psycho you if you spot another
psycho and there's just like this uh
there's a fuckin movie going on there
that I would love to finance you almost
hospitalized me one times from laughing
so hard like I don't know if you
remember this there's 20 people for the
first show and there's a girl Joe Rogan
that's a 12 with a guy that's a four I
said you're very beautiful
and then she just went and ran with it
and started talking about how her
husband pimps are out now you have
rights on such a great time think was
that stuff true and she goes yeah go
show me the monkey she pull down her
pants the girl had a monkey that was
spotless she had nearly stunk I ate it I
fainted or some and then she sucked my
dick she's going the cops had to hold
them back that's all he wanted i side
with joe and bill on this one you're out
of your fuckin mind blue bed made that
so props the blue man
wait what part of that story was funny
for all of it the part that the woman's
husband prostitute sort of comics so
funny we know really I'm serious why is
that funny to you like what part is the
giggle it's like you're asking me like I
figure ask people what part isn't funny
that I don't know where to start what
part is funny the whole thing everything
is funny about it it's funny the way he
tells it it's funny that that that
happened that that's a reality somewhere
all of its funny okay it's funny story
don't you like funny stories I do I just
don't I don't think about I think it's
sad and what part of it sad bummed out
for the girl she liked doing it did she
yeah she was who was all about it this
week so why don't you cry at the end she
cried when she stuck around for the
second show and then he started they she
realized they liked it kind of hit her I
guess the drugs wore off or something
and then she started crying but like
it's funny too
somebody would start crying and saying I
sucked that guy's dick in the show I
would laugh at that would you laugh at
that like she just did it she
volunteered to do it you wouldn't laugh
at that can you bring this up in therapy
what about it
just bring it up I think you need to
work on it
I think it's you don't think it's funny
no why not because it just isn't it's
just not it's not only it's not on my
radar as humorous like the story where
I'm like sad I feel bad for that lady
I left that's half as hard as I left the
first time we tell me that the first
time he told me that I seriously could
have used an oxygen tank okay they left
so hard just like I left it that
wu-tang's story about that's why Bill
thinks you're a psycho it didn't start
there
well I told him that story he did not he
didn't laugh yeah because bill and I
have what's known as empathy you always
say that bullshit he's actually a really
you know sweet guy I'm not you know he's
like tender I'm not sweet guy
cuddle bear no you you are too but I do
feel like you have these dark demons
inside that you're not really letting on
what are you maybe in the rage inside
nobody's stuff I laugh at things that
are inappropriate you know I know as do
i yeah
mental illness makes me laugh a lot
right I think that's that stuff's real
funny you think that that there's no
suitable critique of that quality it's
just not as sadistic as like suffering
like what you're laughing at is that
this woman I'm not even in the story and
you're already that's the difference is
like I'm I'm basically laughing it like
the guy with Tourette's because that's a
silly byproduct of mental illness and I
was a little bit of a neurological
disorder things that schizophrenic
people say is funny to me because it's
just a byproduct of mental illness but
yeah you're laughing at true suffering
it's the be suffering that gives you the
tickle yeah like this woman was drugged
and then her husband pimps her out and
then she gets with Joey Diaz
okay and then during the shows shouts it
out that I sucked that guy's dick and
what does the husband do to her
he wants his $40 he's not mad that she
sucked his dick he's mad that he hasn't
been paid okay yeah so the depravity I
mean I can't believe I would have to
explain what's funny I actually and I'm
being like this isn't shtick or anything
like I genuinely don't know what's funny
like it's sad and depraved when me it's
sad that somebody says I don't know
what's funny
that's what's I'm seriously I know I
know the humor I am so serious when I
say it's sad to me that somebody is like
I don't understand what's funny about
that
that's what said because even in Henry
portrait of a serial killer I do get it
like he snaps the hooker okay yeah and
then the guy looks back and goes and I
that look is funny it's the look that's
funny
to that crazy thing happening but I get
the feeling that you're laughing at the
hookers neck being snapped in the first
class it's the ring please say it it's
also that it's also that like what's
funny about that it's it'd be like if
somebody was like hey these people need
to shut up and then one of them goes and
snap their neck and you're like I didn't
mean like that right like it's like one
of those things that is it's an extreme
it's an extreme reaction to okay but
then I see then I feel but for the
person who just got killed that's where
it's not real it's a fucking movie you
know what about the Asian man that got
his legs crushed and he was screaming
for help and a lot of people agree with
me that that was hilarious a lot what
was funny about about at that time that
I'm what am I missing
oh my god again it's like I feel like
I'm explaining what's funny to my mom or
something right now it's like I mean the
look the sound the fact that the car
kept coming back up the engines revving
the guys how does say words he's yelling
in so much pain yeah
you gotta bring this up what am I
supposed to say just I don't know dude
just explain this to him yeah I'll be
like hey I'm going to talk you about
something I laugh when super funny
things happen and I'm I don't understand
why it's not super funny things it's
super violent things super
inappropriately violent things that hurt
people I just think to like it's a
little suspect you're just loved of
murder and like we'd watch this great
movie together baby driver yeah silly
title great great movie and I'm like
okay good night sweetie I love you I'll
give you a kiss good night and then I
just hear good night
stab stab stab kill can I'm like what
the fuck can't fall asleep to this dude
and yeah and it's like another angry
murder kill but I mean here's what's
funny it's always probably would listen
this and be like oh my god like what
kind of thing are you watching oh it's
this little known series called narcos
on Netflix okay so if it's not narcos
it's usually like and the victim was a
blonde woman a 41 year old mother of one
son named Ellis and they lived in a
suburb of California okay yeah and then
you know then I got to hear that stuff
in the back so what are you saying I'm
gonna murder you
I didn't say you just did that's what
your fear feels like it why cuz i watch
shows no it feels like you do have some
kind of repressed anger that's
expressing itself through your choice of
humor and entertainment like I have to
tell you that I don't watch murder shows
as freak I don't I just never do not
interested but I think not interested
because you're not the only like my
mother's the type to go like oh you just
love these murder shows and then you
have to go like hey do you think that
this murder show was made and then she's
like I hope I hope this one guy watches
it I mean you realize that millions of
people watch ok millions people have
mental problems on my deal people also
like these white bummer movies and
medical dramas I don't like medical
dramas you don't want to watch people
with cancer
ya know I'm the same way fuck that
alright but I think that every night I
mean it's okay
it's the same thing all the time every
night it's murder murder murder kill
kill kill confessions of murderers
murders I like it it's entertaining okay
I would like to watch those shows or
shows of people screaming because they
you know got hit by something right yeah
I told you about that time I left
uncontrolled leena guy's face when he
told me a bathtub was dropped on him
right I know they've heard it before
I think I'm laughing that hard honestly
if I would really break it down because
it's so terrifying maybe to me not alone
you know I mean like murder and these
horrible no not murder murder I'm
talking about like when I laugh really
hard it's so extreme to my psyche and I
kind of fear it in such a way that it's
how I process what's going on in other
words like when that guy told me that
the bathtub was dropped on him and he
was really sincere and like told me what
it did to him I think it wasn't like oh
I'm laughing at your misfortune it was
like I couldn't look at him and process
what was going on so I had to laugh you
know like I laughed to deal with it
mm-hmm you know it's like laughing when
you when you shouldn't laugh yeah you
can't handle the actual feelings about
it I think I can't handle the actual
feeling you can't even go there
I hope that's what's happening yes
uh-huh yeah but that joy di story is
just funny that's just a funny story yep
what inspired you to put this together
what's in the dog oh I just thought it
was funny that uh that I laughed really
hard during that thing and that joy was
like now did Joe say anything at your
ridiculous amount of laughter no I
actually asked him afterwards I go I was
laughing so hard at that and I looked at
you and I saw you like with that
expression you're like I thought that
you you know he was like oh I didn't I
don't remember like we were all smoking
and drinking sure I remember that hem of
his shoe please yeah well but I mean now
that it was funny
together I don't know no you think I
need help yeah please you need help well
yet help thank you every weekly now I'm
having a flashback of a beautiful detail
snow removal up I did just north of here
at a plateau last year
Oh elevate it up like that there hey
that fucking greeter has a plow in the
front wow that's fucking a rear yeah
buddy
that's fucking rear look it's a snow
plow dad motor I can you see how excited
he got about that there's no extensive
video no plow he's like oh my god it has
that feature that's fucking rare
I think that's an old fucking
Freightliner FLD from from the 90s it's
running till there's my thumbnail right
there beautiful whole fucking
Freightliner more even I think I filmed
that truck before and CNN agree oh he
films it regularly right on Yammer man
look at its sleeper on that seat that's
a big rig man that's this guy's accent
from master of accents he this was
filmed in Montreal oh yeah yeah you know
that baby wasn't made after 2009 it
sounds too good snowplow II yeah I mean
this is definitely on the dad boner
everybody has something you love killing
and depravity and this guy likes snow
plows so I'll tell you something guys
this is definitely at first man oh yeah
I mean really I got the same team here
the same company clearing the snow in
this tree here which I don't know what
the hell is called and they just did
that side and they got to do it again
because there was so much snow that's
fucking weird there's actually two teams
see look there's his level of passion
for snow plan is unlike so where you
kind of respect it though right you're
like you really leave this shit I mean
everyone gets excited about something
yeah like this is a I'm just marveling
at the amount of snow that looks
terrifying yeah do you feel
claustrophobic when snow falls like that
claustrophobic
yeah like because I didn't grow up in
that like do you feel I kind of feel
claustrophobic like it's I'm trapped
inside oh no you don't feel like oh my
god the snows gonna take over it's not
only mm-hmm
no no I kind of like it yeah yeah what's
the fun part like what do you like I
mean I don't experience it that more
much anymore so it's a it's kind of a
thrill and you know usually it's snowing
I'm in a hotel or something I'm like oh
I mean it looks beautiful cozy yeah I
like it I like it yeah I like the great
thing about like extremes of weather
well you don't live in it is that I only
experienced it for like 24
yeah do you feel like not doing anything
in that weather though yes that's a
thing yes I'd weigh 200 pounds just cuz
I'd be like well it's time to make some
potato soup Oh for the television that
happens yeah of course I would just
order postmates sand like cozy up some
movies no here's some some emails that
came in
we have a salome translation do blind
people save on electricity brilliant
thought provoker it's a good one
so smart I had a thought while I was Rob
rub rubbing myself to sleep do you think
that blind people will save a shit ton
of money electricity
see you in peenics in december tomorrow
on AMG armando I've never considered
that but as soon as that thought hits
your mind
it's obviously you're like oh that makes
toys it's a silly question but then not
because you're like well well they have
to run like the standards you're heating
your cooling your appliances but they
don't turn the lights on at least I
don't have to they don't have to right I
mean depends on your level of blindness
I've talked to some blind people that
told me that you know there's there's
levels obviously a blindness so there's
people that actually are seeing shades
and shapes and therefore like you know
they sense light coming in that can
affect you know where they see what
their limited sight sees yeah and
there's people that are totally 100%
blind and I turn the lights on just to
prevent like burglars from assuming
nobody's home all right right just a
safety measure well a thrilling question
I blind people let us know yeah it's a
really good one do you want to hear I
got a translation for Soames yeah oh my
god Salameh just to remind people had
not left of or the messages for Salome
had not been left in a long time and
then last week out of nowhere it
happened again I know in months months
almost a year had gone by is that long
yeah so
we moved here which was November of last
year and we're almost in November so a
little bit less than a year unbelievable
unbelievable and I was so excited to
hear it again I was just okay so what
did what was that so this guy writes in
hi my name is Rashid from Los Gatos
California well blows Gatos big fan of
the show translating what the Iranian
woman said on your show basically she's
saying that you need to contact the
termite company and for 450 dollars they
will come and treat your area and then
she said put something white down on the
floors and they will find the termites
that's pretty much my favorite part
about the old solemn a voice they would
translate a lot of them told me he's
like man it is so inappropriate for her
like a woman that is obviously an older
woman to talk the way she talks she's
like she's so vulgar she's saying things
that like street guys there's a
motherfucker I love it yeah she talked a
lot of shit man she's to say that he's
always giving salome advice yeah like
you know but to put bags on the fruit
trees and you need to do this and this
medicine pick it up from here cost a lot
and must be a mother
it must be a mother and aunt a
grandmother some maternal figure in some
amis life god this mystery I really wish
we could find Salamanca find Solomon
listen Persian community can you please
do some intel like fucking and ask
people like this obviously an L a
Persian these are this is the number I
believe in 8 1 8 I think that's like ask
you know oh 3 1 out it's like asking the
LA community find that blonde Amanda let
her know well here's the thing you think
that that's crazy
but immigrant communities like in LA
there's a finite number of Hungarians in
Los Angeles yeah and if I talk to one
hung go I'll be like hey do you know uh
yeah this guy Otto of the storm where me
yeah well Otto's got this daughter
so-and-so do you know her yeah actually
I do
right you can actually try
get down just like you found the kid the
bike's kid that's right
you never know because of the interwebs
so we need the durka detectives durka
detectives to get together and solve the
Salah ministry
yeah somebody knows Salah me there's six
degrees of separation here yeah
absolutely true here the world is much
smaller now because of the interwebs of
course yeah I love it man so way
anything else anymore that we must earn
that or know through emails no no no I'm
saying from that translate is it now
that's it he's like basically that's
that's what's going on an email that
came in on your Sinise hey guys it's
Friday September 15th after countless
hours long sleepless nights extreme
night terrors keeping me from having a
decent family life I would like to
address the research I've been doing on
Tina's sneeze if you listen very closely
she's saying Jada as she sneezes my
theory on this is because after being
told many times that when I was younger
by my elders sneezing feels so good
because you're getting all the bad out
then after hearing of genes longtime
hatred of Jada Pinkett Smith I've kind
of the conclusion that much like a high
number sloppy Brown she couldn't control
letting out with us to be a cry out of
epic proportions she was obviously
hurting inside an extruded Jada's name
in the last-ditch effort to keep the
demons out of her mind and off her back
I hope this helps and I hope I can get
some sleep now it's been a rough month
as I couldn't get the sound out of my
head high
tight and definitely stay non-binary and
white love sky and white I don't hate
Jada Pinkett I don't hate her yeah well
I think I feel like I feel like she's in
a marriage that is probably pretty wacky
I think they got a wacky thing going on
um well anything me just he slams
everybody so what though
and she's like well I'm mrs. Smith I'm
mrs. what I mean who cares who cares
what who cares are these doing that so
what I am NOT wired for that type of a
marriage stop yeah I know but you're
also not married is fuckin well Smith
like think about being married to Will
Smith I picture I picture myself married
to Will Smith and he's like I just
whatever slammed a bunch of hos I do
yeah yeah that's kind of what I signed
up for your Will Smith I guess so that
level of celebrity you can't expect them
to be international movie stars I mean I
don't know that what that was I mean I
know he wasn't like a hardcore rapper
but he was a rapper it's like yeah of
course man you're gonna I guess that's
the trade-off I mean there are a lot of
rich wives but that's what that's the
game sign up for it that's the deal the
milania's of the world are like well I
got ice like this fuckin trolls dick but
I think they like nice tan bags they
sign up when they go it's nice of course
of course you're a hot piece of ass and
yeah and he's a troll and he's got tons
of look he's not even troll Will Smith's
hot yeah I don't know you know what you
married I'll be I couldn't I personally
I got well you know but I mean that's
not what I signed up for
yeah yeah I'm a bunt we're in a bonded
pair you and I are like a couple of
Brussels yeah no yeah I need my new my
jeans yeah the parent when you're gone
I'm just they don't like you I'm not
good
[Music]
I'm reading the hecklers have you guys
are wondering why old man flaccid
penises are always so big they always
walk around locker rooms but ass naked
dick swaying back and forth really
wonder is this because the more boners
you get so much that as an old man you
have a bigger flaccid penis my wife
think it's just the gravity of 80 years
of your dick hanging there we need the
help from the dick detectives keep it
iein tight the coxa Gators Eric and
misty from a really good question I have
seen some big old sloppy dicks in locker
rooms and such but to be fair I've seen
some small old dicks too you know but I
do know what he's talking about that it
appears sloppier and plopping it is
sloppier and floppier because I mean I
think both I don't think all the boners
contribute to it yeah and some of them
you know I mean some of them just have
healthy hogs it just you know it's just
like any portion of the population but
everything is sagging it's yeah you know
we're biological beings that break down
over time and I do think it's like you
said just loose loose skin loose meats
yeah loose everything sags more
everything my tits are a mess
everything's a mess but I've seen little
I've seen little ones on old guys little
painters yeah sure but even the skin
doesn't get hanging on the little penny
yeah
the skin will hang on it but it's still
little but like you know it'll have like
sloppy or tangy balls you know like big
sloppy balls I think the balls are more
affected than the penis forever men male
aging him if I'm not look I haven't see
I haven't seen many old dicks and balls
but on I've seen in you know films or
what yeah but I got to show you this
okay I found a new star for you a strong
performer strong weight we have to watch
this rocco siffredi dyno Jerry why don't
we watch it watch it tonight I'd love to
yeah I saved it because I saw it where
you're let's definitely watch it yeah
but I found a man should see this guy Oh
what is it what's the story I just show
it to you later and we could
talk about next week but I find a new
big dick dangler for you geez
yeah really giving people the business
too you'll like it I will yeah what I
like it are you like it no I definitely
like it but I want to show it to you
okay yeah he's a porno star yeah yeah
yeah oh boy I don't know if I need it in
my life quite honest I think you might
be like and you know yeah you Nance
that was so fucking cool God people
watching on YouTube I don't even want to
repeat what you just did well they just
saw it yeah but people just listening to
the show don't know I'm not even gonna
repeat what I do
did your own porno move like a porno
girl I saw hot yeah so fun huh I love
shooting it's so fucked up do you think
those girls are do you think there there
must be some girls that genuinely like
love it love fucking bang whores and
then there's some girls that are telling
themselves yes and then there are girls
are so high that they're like what do I
have to say to do this all of your
theories are correct what do I have to
say to make $150 today all of your
theories are right
oh you're gonna sneeze and then you're
gonna go oh that sneeze felt so good oh
that was terrible that was terrible oh I
can't believe I even brought this up
what yesterday you came home and we
ordered some Thai food and I had the
penne and curry and you had your yellow
curry
are you done I think so yeah you got
snot in your mustache it feels so good
it doesn't feel good go go right now
okay I feel high I really enjoy that
yeah holding up the whole show now tom
just go nobody wants to hear it so I we
had our curries and then like 15 minutes
after you ate we were sitting in the
kids playroom planning a play-doh
and you were like oh I just farted that
wasn't good that was real bad and you
went what is that what is that when you
eat something yeah
let's talk about it and like within 10
minutes you can feel the water it's not
it's not what you just ain't right it's
what you ate previously that's my theory
no no old shit what's being pushed out
right but what you just ate is
triggering it's triggering its
contributing it's not spicy curry on top
of something nasty that you had earlier
it's not a good formula man it really
but let's do some let's do some
detective work on that was terrified
some Sherlock work we were sitting in
there with rounded in the playroom yeah
and then I was like but she listened my
eyes bugged out I was like oh wow
because of the smell are because there
was something there well we just it was
hot and I could feel my stomach going I
clinched I was like oh my god I went on
the toilet it was like opening a faucet
just a brown faucet go on a milan faucet
it was liquid it was really liquid 100%
seven yeah and did it burn not really
see that's what leads me to believe it's
not what you just ate it's what you ate
previously you're right and like what
you just can't come out that fast
but it's making you yours your digestive
system is going like whoa we need to
clear out this yeah problem right now
and then they said you took this morning
took you about 20 minutes I noticed it
took a long time it was more normal a
little more of a grind but more normal I
was probably smelly from the curry I
didn't really register the smell I can't
remember oh it was what number was it
this morning was probably uh three
that's not bad
no I was very small which I'm surprised
because I had poop soup when I came off
the road and I had some curry last night
our boy had it had a diaper full of
pellets when I woke up right pellets
what does that mean hard oh that was
yesterday when I got tumor from his nap
they're hard they were like little balls
oh he needs a more fiber mm-hmm
he will heat vegetable to save his life
right now no this morning's was better
what'd it look like just more of a
little slop yeah that's normal
yeah how do you tile it train the kid
when they make like slops I mean is that
because there's a diaper mushing we're
supposed to get into it right now by
them I know but how do you train
somebody whose shit is like mush
it's like oatmeal do you not I mean how
do I train that and then we gotta clean
up everything no no I just don't
understand because my browns don't look
like that there's those are baby Browns
you know his stomach is the intestines
are still developing oh yeah I guess you
just let them diarrhea and the it's not
diarrhea it's just not a normal baby
shit yeah
these have softer grounds you know it's
great as we've been training him on the
word dump mm-hmm I've been saying I have
so excited mommy's gotta take a dump you
want to come with me and then of course
he wants to come and sit on my lap while
I take a shit but he likes to say poopoo
mmm he likes poopoo because it's easier
to say but I'm probably better for his
life for like interacting with other
children and like they adults that will
be in those settings for him to say go
poopoo yeah okay dump we even made the
nanny laugh no our nanny is a pretty
reserved adorable Guatemalan lady and
she's very proper and we even made her
laugh with the dump thing yeah she
started laughing she knows that's not
right
take a dump check this out I think this
might be is this in st. lous tits where
is st. Louis is that in Mexico is that
where I'm going this week Mexico st.
Louis Mexico Missouri where is st. Louis
I don't even know Missouri
again where's Missouri it's not away no
I know it's got the Arc de Triomphe or
the Arc de Triomphe the golden arches
they're called golden arches no no
that's McDonald's no now you got me
telling people come and the golden
oranges yeah when you get this st. Louis
is basically all dedicated to McDonald's
I think I want to go larger yeah was he
wrong McDonald
this is where like headquarters I
watched the right ray Croft movie I know
that that's nothing I was really cool
that Uwe texted me like I'm watching
this movie about the McDonald's founder
and reminds me a lot of you he's such a
piece of shit he's such a POS he steal
some dudes wife he rips off the original
co-founder and made you think of me well
he just looks like you he acts like you
things like you that's all
small stunts check this out
this is in Houston we hosted pointed
this out before about when people that
you that they don't fit the way they
talk they said yeah yeah that's a new
genre in our show I like what Mitch and
you see it with you know there's certain
that's a black guy talking that's a
white guy all right yeah last week
that's crazy
that's not from last week that's from
like three years ago the pimp guy that's
not a pimp but it is a white guy
who talks like a panther but then
there's you know there's other people
that you know we've that like that you
know that girl who's like oh you know um
was her name forget her name but she
this might be her right yeah she's Asian
right yeah she's she's a ghetto though
yes what issue without them Ali she's on
their makeup boys a bitch where I'm
still cute as shit get the fuck out of
here I might look a little bit more
chicken chong ching chong don't get me
fucked up bitch I'm still heard of shit
and will fuck your ass up she's Asian
yeah that's wild right like you don't
normally hear asian chick is talking
like that and it obviously exists this
is in Houston it's a it's like a little
convenience store the Asian dude is
behind the counter looks like all the
customers are black he's talking mad
shit to one of his customers so we don't
know what's leading up to the shit
talking but you get the feeling that the
Asian guy is justified like that the
other guy has I don't know started
something said something
but it's just wild to see an Asian dude
I think like this right I mean that is
crazy not just like it's not that it's
an Asian dude that is but like that he
talks like that
what's your bitch comes around the
corner gets in this dude's face right
doesn't that seem it's always jarring
when someone doesn't look like the
accent that's correct out of their mouth
right I mean you talk like that it's not
that it's not possible but you're just
like that's not that's why even talk
about it to a much lesser degree how
people react to me when I speak Spanish
and they're like oh I didn't think you
right it's like a small thing they're
like I mean there's obviously people who
look like me who speak Spanish but they
still react like I just didn't expect
that out of you you know it's like when
you hear this dude talk this way and he
looks like this it's crazy yeah it's
like stunning
[Music]
perhaps a big word I mean you got me
call me that's no big words he's really
part of the community if he can drop
that trick it means it's a shit
trick-ass bitch what do you say like you
ain't gonna do shit you bitch ass you
bitch ass ain't gonna do a goddamn thing
finally for those were just listening
this is an Asian guy yeah that's an
agency who doesn't look aggressive at
all
damn homie that maybe that's just what
it's like to live in Houston you start
talking like that I guess if you're
around that all the time you would
definitely pick it up it'd be hilarious
to find out his story that's what I know
I want to know like did you immigrate to
this country and you showed up and you
were like oh like trying to figure out
the culture and and then you just were
immersed in gas station Houston culture
yeah and like that's you're like this is
the world I grew up in
well definitely I mean if we hear
English speakers like his second
language and they pick it up they learn
it like British English yeah yeah yeah
then you're like wow you talk all fancy
like you're from England right native
but he sounds like a native English
speaker right I don't think he sounds
like you know he's native but he's
native to houston gas station what I'm
saying he doesn't sound like he learned
no after he's just culturally from this
gas station like this guy's at this gas
station that's right my parents when my
mother learned English watching American
television shows Lee sitcoms
yeah like watching Sanford and Son and
all in the family so she knew like a lot
of sassy phrases and you're like way out
of you all right
how do you know like talk to the hand
that's like this is a stone man you boys
better know you just can't come in any
kind of stove with that bullshit
Ryuto realto see it so hughes again tell
that asian dude was counting some when
he said that motherfucker got me fucked
up which is like real specific to be
like for that to be part of your
vernacular is pretty you know it's it's
like you you don't just like here a show
once and start saying that yeah that
dude has been immersed in this for a
long time it's wild man yeah it is
I could watch i would watch a a camera
lock into this gas station on a 24-hour
I just keep playing that guy I give this
guy a TV show Kylie Jenner I watch this
guy all day I mean talk to me shit just
dude like he got heated where it's a
tough kid did you imagine working at a
gas station I mean it has to be such a
dangerous job you know late at night and
also people are just most the time
coming to get fucked up you don't like
your people are like it make I get that
book me get hostile cigars cigarettes
liquor and beer liquor stores I mean
there's no such a dangerous job no
midnight on a Saturday night right now
I've got scared walking into gas
stations like I need to pay for his gas
I just go to the bathroom and you're
like I didn't get the fuck out of here I
think it's a really bad idea that they
sell alcohol at gas stations yeah like
this is a place where you get in your
car and drive I don't know it's just it
does attract a CD or element to these
places it shouldn't be CD like why
should a gas station be CD at all it
shouldn't be no they all are yeah cuz of
cigarettes and alcohol yeah that's where
you get it yeah no I mean there's I
pulled in the gas stations before and
thought it was so shady I go drive to
find another one but in different states
in the US don't they separate that stuff
out like I know you can always buy
alcohol in grocery stores like on the
news post even in Colorado I think
though they have separate there's
there's stores that have different laws
for counties so you can have a
tri-county and then the
it's county over you can buy alcohol
yeah I don't think they should sell I
call it gas stations and no no but it's
big business a lot of money they like a
lot of money fifty what do you feel
about I guess this is a question about
this eating on the turlet as we all know
there's a party popular why I made page
on Facebook I've noticed recently
there's a rise in mommy's thinking it's
okay to literally eat where they shit I
can't believe this is absolutely
horrific trend is going unnoticed and
widely accepted do you think it's okay
to eat on the turlet I personally
believe it's the only way to get as fat
as burnt Chrysler stay high and tight
mommy Tina will always be my main mommy
if she was my mom I would want to marry
her
just like the gays Sariah or is that a
funny way of saying Sarah Sarah they are
YHA say it Sarah
Syria Sherea Sherea eat on the turlet
what do you think gene I didn't when I
was a little girl I have a vivid memory
of being constipated during dinner like
I had to shit but then I also had to eat
and my mother bringing me a bowl of
spaghetti to eat as I was shitting on
the toilet rock yeah what I do it now as
an adult no I mean I accidentally walked
in the bathroom with a mouthful of food
yesterday and felt creepy like chewing
what was in my mouth to sit down and pee
that felt gross yeah I mean there's so
much poo and I don't bring me old flakes
onto that onto the toilet you know I
have run coffees in you know because
sometimes the coffee is making you brown
just keep bringing in the toilet I
wouldn't do that and I don't do that
only because there's poo everywhere like
the bacteria I don't even think like
that I just like what I mean why
wouldn't you just go back to your food
like just why are you bringing it to the
toilet oh the two birds with one stone
you're eating and shitting like that's
the it's like symbiotic yeah it's
synergy synergy I don't know man
I'm not a big simple I mean it's a
time-saver I'm not gonna lie I like the
theory of it I just don't think it's
very hygienic yeah I don't I don't think
you should I think there's a lot of poo
in the air and that's how you get sick
yeah I think you should just
you should eat men shit shit then heat
and if you have food that you want to
eat and you also this shit just wait
well because you're gonna wipe and then
what touch your bowl and then put your
bowl down and then wash your hands so
now you've you've got your sandy you
could be holding a sandy okay then what
do you do it so you put the okay let's
walk through it I'm shitting I'm eating
the sandy well first of all you walk it
with one hand you lift the toilet seat
up that's contaminated your hands
already contaminated
it's got shit flecks on it yeah I mean
like microbial shit flex yeah I'm
sitting down I'm shitting I'm shitting
I'm eating I'm eating and then oh it's
time to wipe know what do i do at the
sandy you finish it well I'm not a fast
eater like you yeah I'm gonna say it's
half half done I'm gonna put that on a
dirty counter with shit flex that on the
air put it on the ground I'm gonna wipe
why you I'm you put it in between your
feet on the ground yeah and then you
pick it up and you finish eating so
revolting
some people are nasty as hell yes he has
motherfucking hell right now I tell you
so Sarah Tiana you know Sarah Teague
comedian she and I went to Afghanistan
together and we stayed we stayed in
Kandahar Afghanistan and in Kandahar is
what's known as the poo pond yeah where
they put all the sewage from the base
into this pond and they churn it it
churns so you smell shit wafting
throughout the base
what is that John it's the poop on of
kin her now what happened was many many
weeks later she got very very very ill
with meningitis and in Atlanta she was
in Atlanta visiting your mother cause
did they go
were you bite you know if I poo any time
and she knows that I was in Kandahar
about a month ago they go I could
definitely do it to you like in the air
that's right whoa just having it and
that's how you get things like like just
floating in the air and people touch
their hands their mouths and the next I
guess the counter-argument is that like
maybe to make you stronger so you should
get more maybe it was less than a month
actually I would say like a couple weeks
after we got back maybe you should be
doing it maybe you should be eating on
the toilet more to me I guess we settled
it all your meals on the toilet and I
also heard while you're
potty training your kids that they get
pinkeye more because they're touching
their you know yeah
you can't look we gotta actually run
this week I have a very full day today
and on the toilet I'm gonna throw that
soon as I get out of here
anything else you need to add gene
anything you say for those we don't know
my Netflix special comes out October
10th mother inferior so get ready to
watch that October 10 on that frame very
exciting very exciting amaze exciting to
maze I just saw artwork I just saw
trailer very excited it's all being
worked on right now so the title card
the title shows up at the card itself
isn't up yet sorry we thought it would
be but they're still finalizing the
artworks and it'll be up very soon yeah
it's an excellent special thank you guys
again for listening here is FA RT by
Billy robot we will see you next week we
have a great guest next week
[Music]
get construction workers back to work in
Alberta why is this government treat
Alberta like a fart in the room that
nobody wants to talk about or
acknowledge
[Music]
[Applause]
point of order point of order point of
order point of order
[Music]
[Applause]